so week ago I decided to try to create a
computer file video completely from
scratch just using free software I don't
mean free software where you're giving
it bundled with a computer or that you
can download for free off the internet
and then the new dalish but I can't even
say new definition of free software and
the video that I'm trying to make it's
not actually published as I'm recording
this is with Matt Lee who's a chap who
used to work for the Free Software
Foundation so he's deaf and what free
software is in their eyes and it's all
about freedom of speech as opposed to
free as in money go and have a look at
that video if you want to know more but
this thing that he said when I was
interviewing him struck me so it was
this bit here no video editing isn't
always the easiest thing to do with free
software it can be done right people do
edit video with free software all the
time and you know video editing software
is somewhat in its infancy as free
software he said it videos editing
software's somewhat in its infancy in
free software terms and I discovered
there were lots of free applications out
there to do video editing on not all of
them met my needs and not all of them
were reliable and not all of them were
that easy to install so the other thing
about this video that I'm making now
that I'm to try to explain the process I
went through I'm just trying to explain
the process I am NOT flying a flag for
any specific bit of software I'm not
doing a tutorial on how to use those
bits of software many of you guys out
there know a lot more about those sorts
of things than I do all I tried to do
was say right ok I'm a user I'm used to
editing video let's see if I can do it
free software so I was going to actually
do this as a blog post and explain all
of the things that had gone through and
I thought well no we're computer file we
make computer videos let's see if the
average user ie me can go out there and
do something like video editing for free
so I prefer what I term as the blunt
under the camera which is a bit without
the lens on it so apologies for me
fluffing my way through this but I did
think it'd be worth as just explaining
very briefly how we make or how we shoot
a computer file video that way you'll
understand what I needed to be able to
get out of the free
software what do we do when we shoot a
computer file video well we obviously
use a camera sometimes more than one
camera that's why there's another one
here for the moment we obviously need to
record the audio of whoever it is we're
interviewing now most cameras will
record at least two channels of audio
and we use one of those with this kind
of microphone that you can see here on
me that's a lapel mic that's the main
microphone that we use the other
microphone is a microphone on the camera
often called the top mic it's used as
backup the idea is if something goes
wrong with this and we don't notice it
we've at least got that to rely on now
when you come to edit that means ideally
you want to throw away the audio off
that microphone so first of all we need
to be ability to be able to split out
what's recorded as a stereo track into
two mono tracks in order to choose which
of those mono tracks we want people to
be able to listen to so that's one thing
is very important the other thing is
that the camera that I use is quite a
high dynamic range and that means it's
able to capture a lot in the low lights
that shadows the dark areas what you're
seeing here probably and quite a lot in
the high light so perhaps the lights
coming down here or the light on the
screen when that comes to video you then
need to change the contrast to basically
allow video to be able to see all of
those things so if you can see this shot
here of map that I did quite a snatched
interview on the steps of the station
you can see it was very bright behind
him and well his face was correctly
exposed but then he obviously had a
black top on so when I came to edit this
originally I would do something on the
contrast to basically make that a bit
more palatable and the editing software
I'm showing you here is avid media
composer it's one of the industry
standards for video editing this is not
free software but to make this project a
reality what I decided to do is edit it
in my normal way so that I knew what I
was looking for and then go and try and
recreate that on a free piece of
software that way at least I wasn't
learning the software and making the
creative decisions at the same time so
in a moment I'll show you the free
software that I ended up using but I
just wanted to explain something of the
process so on this video editing
software here we've got our sauce
pictures and we've got what we're going
to do is our edit and then down the
bottoms what's called a timeline
people know one of those is in this
video editing software it splits into V
for video tracks and a for audio tracks
and you can see that it's fairly
straightforward wherever there's a
change in a block here it's an edit
point and some things where I floated
something over the top and right at the
end at the promo section here you can
see quite a lot going on that's because
of several layers of video going to make
that there's each of the four looking
sub screens there's the background
there's the text on top of there so
that's quite a lot of video going on
there this Windows 7 machine which runs
the editing software also runs
after-effects and various other bits and
pieces like Photoshop and audio editing
for when I need to do that but is kept
completely separate from anything else
it does have a network link to rest on
my system but I have this machine here
as an admin machine for uploading to the
internet for checking emails etc etc so
what I've ended up doing is the video
edit has happened on my admin machine
which is really really slowed me down in
a lot of respects but this machine here
is running Ubuntu 1204 but the whole
idea of this came about the fact that on
top of all of this I have a backup
machine that I thought I might be able
to rejuvenate this old machine that I
just have for backup purposes put
something on it that might actually work
and just be a video editor in the end
that went to pot my ended up using my
admin machine because it's a bit more
powerful I'll go through those specs of
the machines in a moment that suffice to
say that my admin machine used to be my
main machine running avid it's a quad
core fairly decent machine from a few
years ago with 4 gigs of RAM easily able
to handle HD video so the other machine
the old machine which is on a keyboard
and monitor and mouse switch here this
is where I started this experiment on
this machine here which is probably
going to finish the experiment as well
and I'll kind of come to that in a
moment I tried to put on open suzi twice
I tried to load open Susi onto it
installation failed for no apparent
reason well obviously there was a reason
that it didn't let me know what it was
Debian I thought that would be a good
bet so I put Debian on it I got the
black screen of death that I'm calling
it a mouse pointer you could see but
nothing else tried installing that three
or four times spent a lot of time on
Debian typing things into the command
prompt
terminal I could get to using Google to
try and find different ways of trying to
get graphics drivers to make my system
work we didn't get anywhere with it went
for new Sense news sense nuisance new
sense because it was recommended by the
free software foundation that's what
it's running at the moment it's done
quite well on that but I didn't just go
straight to that I also tried a diabolic
which I thought a great potential that's
a fantastic looking thing which I've
still got the CD for cuz I plan to use
or try again comes a cinelerra which is
a piece of software which looked quite
promising
so could only get it to run off the CD
couldn't get it to run off the hard
drive that's probably my fault
ok so you get this splash screen at the
top and then if you go into sound and
video you'll find an application called
cinelerra and I believe you can run this
on different distros personal error
loads up and looks very promising I did
have some problems with it though I
couldn't seem to get audio to work and
output was a problem so some of the
things we were coming out with was this
less than 2 minutes long yet nearly 2
gigabytes in size and obviously some
kind of problem with the colors there
and this which looked really promising
but again mute even outputting an mp3
file was suddenly mute so what I did
think at that point was it's a promising
bit of software and what I decided it
was try and run it on one of the more
powerful machines the admin machine or
even my main wind surfing machine
because it would have run off the CD so
wouldn't run upon even either my admin
machine which is quite a you know decent
machine called 2 quad Nvidia video card
or this which is a Z on an Intel Xeon
machine 2.8 quad-core processor so very
decent decent spec machines and that's
where I went off to try a bun 2 and then
I got to a point where I thought why am
i bothering with the bun 2 on this when
I've already got a bun 2 on a more
powerful machine which is why I ended up
making the the video on my admin machine
the graphics on computer file that's all
of this stuff you can see here was all
created in Adobe After Effects and
Photoshop but I've recreated them for
the video that I put out last I
recreated them
I know they're not animated and I
probably could have done that if I'd had
more time to work in things like blender
which is another free piece of software
unfortunately I've spent a week on this
now and the biggest bottleneck apart
from learning the software has been
finding software that will work
most of my machines here have got in
fact all of these three machines have
got Nvidia video cards in unfortunately
Nvidia and Linux don't always play that
well together
there are ways around it you guys know a
lot more about that and I do what I
don't have time for is spending hours
and hours and hours trying to find the
right thing to make it work so this is
probably the whole point of the exercise
in one nutshell the guys are over at NU
and the Free Software Foundation and
Matt who I spoke to are very very keen
on the idea of free doesn't just mean
how much it costs but for me the
trade-off is between how much time it
takes to get it working and how much it
costs as opposed to the freedom of
speech thing so I understand the point
of freedom speech I think it's fantastic
I like the idea of it and I think
there's room for both things in this
world so what are you doing
well I created the computer file
graphics from scratch very impressed
with it very close to what I'm used to
using in things like Photoshop perhaps
they don't look quite exactly the same
but used to make the thumbnail for
the video which is this here I also use
to make the start plate which is
binary background with the computer file
logo on it I was able to do everything I
wanted to do in not quite as
quickly and easily in Photoshop to
deselect something is ctrl + D and in
that duplicates it so I did that a
few times I had lots and lots of copies
of things running around all the while
was trying various bits of software I
was also tweeting about my progress
because while trying things on my old
banging machine I actually started
running with kdenlive
on the admin machine just as a sort of
run to experiments at the same time it
allowed me to start trying different
distros on one machine while I could
also make a start on the edit which is
probably why I ended up with kdenlive
because I got a bit more familiar with
it but
I did get a tweet from somebody saying
try pitivi which again looked really
promising it looked a bit like kdenlive
but a little bit clearer on what we've
going on with the audio and when I ran
clips as it was really promising
fantastic
the moment I put anything on the
timeline though it locks up so that the
timeline looks like it works you can
trim the tracks move them around but I
can't see anything and can't play
anything on the timeline so I did get a
little bit disappointed with this I mean
it appears to do what I wanted to do but
nothing really seems to work playing
doesn't work the other thing someone
suggests he was using blender now I've
experimented with blender for graphics
3d graphics for computerphile
haven't yet got competent enough to to
produce something for a film but I can
see how powerful it isn't what a
wonderful tool that could be and so I've
fired up blender went to the video
editing layout and just looked at it
when I don't know where to start and of
course by this time I'm starting to use
kdenlive getting quite comfortable with
it so I will give this some more time I
believe there's some really good
tutorials online so I will check those
out so opening up kdenlive just have a
look at the software itself and just to
see what it was I was trying to achieve
it looks pretty similar to avid you've
got a timeline at the bottom you've got
the source and record windows now they'd
in this case we've just got one window
but it's tabbed you've got a what they
call a clip and a project monitor and
then you media at this side here which
is kind of where I keep my media in avid
so the timelines look pretty similar so
what did I need to achieve when I talked
about the dynamic range of the image and
I also talked about the audio so in avid
here you can see one single audio track
but in kdenlive if we just make that a
bit larger you'll notice that it's a
stereo track that's what the two
different waveforms within the one block
means so there was no apparent way to
split that out into two separate
waveforms to get my different left and
right or channel 1 and channel 2 as I
referred what that means is that those
two microphones are mixed together now
why is that a problem well if you let
both of those go out and mix together
you can have an echo effect basically if
these two microphone
are picking up the same source ie my
voice in this instance but from slightly
different distances away this
microphones here that microphones over
there and as a result you get a curry
also that's a directional microphone so
it's pointing over my shoulder so in
this instance it's not so much of an
issue but soon was recording Matt it was
pointing over his shoulder at the
traffic so really do want to get rid of
that audio that was a problem on
kdenlive
because of this stereo pair what I did
was I chose the effect called audio
channels copy channels and allowed it to
copy channel 1 to channel 2 and that I
think is where the problem lies in the
clicking audio that everyone is heard on
the right-hand channel of the free
software video whether it's me not
knowing exactly what the settings are or
a slight bug I'm not entirely sure but
that's what you'll find is going on I'm
basically wanting to lose channel 2 and
just have channel 1 so if I were to go
back to the original source media here
in avid for instance and listen to it
mixed it's not free software because
first of all you can't run iTunes for
any book huge amounts of traffic noise
if I lose channel 2 it's not free
software because first of all you can't
write we can hear my quite clearly if we
were to lose channel 1 just to give you
the difference this is what the top mics
doing free software
you can hear him you can hear in
speaking but it's quite a way it's not
quite as nice unfortunately when I did
what I thought would give the same
result over here and kdenlive we got
this an hour initially that's just a
playback issue and when you export it
channel one or the left-hand channel is
absolutely fine in channel two has got a
few clicks on it unfortunately it took
so long to export the file and put it
together that I only really found this
out just before I was going to go live
with the video now many of you out there
might think well you need to fix it and
sort it out but I'd already spent a week
on this video and I just thought this
actually reflected reality of no agendas
to try and kind of get across here this
is just me trying to show what happened
to me trying to do what I need to do the
other thing that I needed to do as well
was sort out this differences dynamic
range this picture difference and I
found some really good tools in kdenlive
for that you've got the input and output
black levels what I didn't quite like
was that here they were just arbitrary
numbers zero to a thousand where I
didn't really know what that meant so I
was changing things like the black level
which you can hopefully see if I come
out of the way and what I wanted to do
was just to take that with your
threshold we're in avid what you would
do is you would use the color correction
tool and you would use a thing called
the RGB parade which is this thing here
and you need to get things within
certain limits on that scope so Kayne
life I keep saying it's really good
piece of software because I think it is
it's just a problem with workflow and
the workflow that I use didn't fit with
kdenlive
so there are lots of people out there
saying I use Kane live or I use blender
or I use pitivi or I use whatever and it
works fine
well it might work fine on your hardware
and with the things that you want to do
even you want to do a massively
complicated video edit but you haven't
decided to lose one of your channels of
audio that might be the only reason that
that mine is not work quite so well so
hopefully that gives people out there a
sense of what I think went wrong on this
as far as the audio is concerned I have
heard clicking like that occurring when
audio is being transcoded from 40 or
converted from 48 kilohertz to forty
four point one killers before so perhaps
that's what's going
there aren't many options in the copy
channels effect so I can't be sure of
that
audio wasn't the only problem I had
though we've came live after I'd got the
edit ready and I thought I was I was
good to go I then had to try and get it
out of the system and exporting was my
next big hurdle I started work on the
free software film on Thursday the 6th
of November I possibly started
installing software on Wednesday the 5th
this is a list basically of all the
different export tests what you'll
notice is lots of these have zero bytes
because they failed or crashed some of
them are only a few K which for a video
file is either incomplete or hideously
compressed and then occasionally you see
one that's what I call a decent sized R
15 Meg file for 30 seconds and what I'd
found over the course of experiments and
going literally through the list of
options on export was that only some of
them worked and only some of them work
with video so for instance I some of
them would only give me audio with those
wonderful clicks that we all know about
so that's just the visualizer in the
movie player some of them would give me
what I wanted but the quality was not
very good so again I'll give you a
close-up of this but it's very very
blocky and not good enough I finally hit
upon an export setting that worked and
it was this one and this is what you
ended up with other software is that
other software is designed to
unfortunately it wouldn't render at this
level of quality or this quality in this
file format but more than about 40
seconds without crashing so 40 seconds
segments were about its limit I tried 60
seconds it crashed so I settled on
choosing 30-second segments of the film
and I out put the film in thirty-second
segments and then I had to knit it back
together again after it the original
film that I've got here that I edited as
a guide I've exported as well to put up
as an unlisted video alongside so people
can see the difference and that took
slightly longer than seven or eight
minutes to export from avid the entire
thing these is 20 minutes for every 30
seconds section so a six-minute film is
12 sections 20 minutes each you can do
the math maths maths math
it's taken quite a few hours to just get
it out of the system really and that's
me being kind saying 20 minutes these
are more than twenty minutes plus I have
to mark up the sections frame accurately
and make sure that I get exactly the
right part and of course I'm then going
to have to put it all together
afterwards upload it and hopefully you
guys have already seen the results of
that got a piece of software called MKV
merge what it is able to do is put files
together as long as they've been encoded
the same and stitch them together
Without Really encoding them and that's
really important at anything to video
because every time you rien code
something you a lose quality and B have
to wait a long time I did cheat a little
bit as well the format that comes out of
this camera here is a format called AVC
HD and it's very heavily compressed and
if you remember the film we did with Tom
Scott on animated gifts you talked about
the idea of size as in size of a file
versus ability to play that file and the
idea that gifts are very very large
because they're dead easy to play
whereas a smaller more compressed file
isn't as easy to play well it certainly
comes into its own with this as well and
what it means is that heavily compressed
video like AVC HD that you'll be
recorded in I'm being recorded in I'm
being recorded in now by that camera is
very difficult to playback my old
computer wouldn't even be able to
playback the raw files nevermind edit
them so what I did was I transcoded them
and cheated a little bit and made it
into HD V which is a slightly easier to
handle format I won't go into the
technical side of all that right now you
can google it but hopefully this is
giving you a little bit of an insight as
to what it's what it's meant to to try
and make one of these videos with free
software
so get out there if you've got time and
if you've got hardware but you'll
strapped for cash download these bits of
software because they're good a really
good and people are putting time and
effort into making them work and all I
would say is don't expect it to work out
of the box like a box piece of software
don't expect to be able to basically
take you back to the shop if it doesn't
do exactly we're expecting it to but
there that's the real trade-off isn't it
it's free